MAX SALTONSTALL: Today
we're talking about the ROI
for Anthos, some price cuts,
and new DataProc features.
I'm Max Saltonstall, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest-latency news.
One of the key tenets
of Google Cloud
is helping our users save
money while empowering
them to do more.
But don't take our word for it.
Check out Forrester's new
technology projection.
In the total economic
impact of Anthos,
they found key
financial benefits
across operational efficiency,
developer productivity,
security productivity,
and customer retention.
So read through and reap some
of those benefits yourself.
And speaking of budgets, we
just announced price cuts
for the NVIDIA T4 GPU.
Google Cloud is
committed to making
GPU acceleration
accessible to all users,
from garages to corporations.
With the reduced cost
of NVIDIA T4 instances,
we now have a broad
selection of accelerators
for a multitude of workloads,
performance levels, and price
points.
In the land of
DataProc, we've just
graduated several new features
to generally available which
extend our data science and
machine learning capabilities.
Autoscaling and notebooks
can help streamline
your environment, while
accelerator support for GPUs
saves you some effort when
you're working on deep learning
models.
So go deep and let us
know what you think.
And in the world of G Suite,
we've just acquired AppSheet.
AppSheet has been
powering businesses
with its no-code platform,
making it simple for anyone
to leverage Google Sheets,
or Maps, or Cloud Functions,
or whatever their heart dreams
of into an application that
can automate and simplify
the workday for everyone.
Welcome to the team, y'all.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.